the Department of Homeland Security is
demanding airlines and airports
worldwide tighten their security so
terrorists cannot smuggle bombs onto
planes now those changes will force more
than 300,000 passengers a day to deal
with new security measures and screening
technology officials say the alternative
would be to widen a ban on carry-on
electronics that now affects eight
countries in Africa and the Middle East
Chris Van Cleve is at Reagan National
Airport outside Washington Chris good
morning
well good morning these heightened
security measures will affect 180
airlines flying about 2100 flights a day
to the US and comes amid growing concern
about terrorists targeting aviation
especially with laptop based bombs that
may be able to get past some airport
screening we cannot play in a national
whack-a-mole with each new threat the
Department of Homeland Security told
airlines serving about 280 airports in
105 countries basically everywhere US
airliners fly from to ratchet up
security or face a potential electronics
band that means flyers coming to the
United States should expect to see
increased scrutiny including canines and
potential secondary screening especially
of laptops let me be clear security is
my number-one concern
our enemies are adaptive and we have to
be adaptive as well this new security
burden will largely fall on Airlines the
group representing US carriers supports
increased security but complained this
decision should have been subject to a
greater degree of collaboration and
coordination as to not inconvenience the
traveling public you can make a really
secure aviation system but nobody's
flying if you do that peter neffenger is
the former TSA administrator it doesn't
surprise me that that we've gotten to a
point where we say you know we think
we've got to do something a little bit
different particularly given that
certain groups have been working on
developing devices to put into laptops
DHS has called for improving detection
equipment to combat the threat of bombs
hidden inside laptops this month the
agency started testing high-definition
three
the CT scanners for carry-on bags at
Phoenix Sky Harbor Airport the bad guy
is very agile and always changing where
we need to be that agile that test
program is set to expand to Boston by
the end of the month and likely other
cities in the coming weeks now
DHS did not disclose what these new
enhanced security measures are but the
airline's say they'll begin implementing
at least some of them within the next
three weeks
they are expecting some disruptions and
delays for fliers Gail all right that's
not good news thank you very much Chris